we're going to continue our coverage of
the supreme court decision to overturn
roe v wade now this follows nearly half
a century of conflict and a concerted
campaign by anti-abortion groups long
before this weekend's protest we have
seen violence against abortion clinics
and the providers too infrequently
vicious and vicious is the word
harassment of women seeking abortions
there has also been a relentless effort
to change the landscape politically in
congress legislatures and the courts jan
crawford takes a look at how we got here
in a landmark ruling the supreme court
today legalized abortions in 1973 roe
versus wade was a bombshell the
anti-abortion laws of 46 states were
rendered unconstitutional
states had only recently passed laws
legalizing some form of abortion while
13 others had begun allowing it with
restrictions by stepping in to make
abortion legal nationwide some justices
at the time hoped the decision would end
the debate over abortion rights
but the anti-abortion rights movement
mobilized almost immediately beginning
first at the grassroots level this is
the first march for life and that was a
year exactly after row came down exactly
jeannie mancini is president of march
for life the march has grown younger and
bigger almost every single year how
important has it been to have that
yearly reminder that we're still here i
can't
think of a more symbolic picture of roe
not being settled law than seeing the
growing number of marchers that social
movement became more strategic in 1992.
today three reagan bush
appointees stabbed the pro-life movement
in the back the supreme court was poised
to overturn roe by a 5-4 vote until a
last-minute switch by justice anthony
kennedy who joined fellow republican
nominees sandra day o'connor and david
suter to save it that moment in 1992 was
deeply disappointing it also helped me
understand how much we could depend upon
republicans which is how much which is
not much that was the point where we
realized unless we strengthen this
political arm at the center of the
movement we will continue to lose within
months marjorie dannenfelser who's been
called the woman who killed roe founded
that political organization susan b
anthony pro-life america every time
there was a devastating blow the
pro-life movement grew
that is the mark of a successful
movement the next devastating blow came
in the 2000s i would welcome a
circumstance where there was such a
consensus in this country that we said
we don't want to have abortion in this
country at all but that's not where we
are when dan felser said republicans
paid lip service to the movement and
lost the presidency twice we said no way
is this ever going to happen again we're
going to reward our friends punish our
political enemies in 2014 the group
helped defeat several pro-abortion
rights senators from battleground states
and in 2016 got assurances from donald
trump the justices that i'm going to
point will be pro-life they will have a
conservative bent and that is why we are
here today talking about the overturn of
roe versus wade
[Music]
activists on the left joined in the
fight arguing abortion bans put lives in
danger and pouring millions of dollars
into recruiting and supporting
candidates but this court decision has
some admitting they've fallen short this
is a concerted coordinated effort and
yes they're winning a conservative legal
movement spent the decade since roe
promoting politicians and legal scholars
who believed it was not the role of
judges to create new rights in the
constitution including abortion rights
president trump succeeded in nominating
three to the supreme court i'm very
proud that roe versus wade is now gone i
didn't think it would happen in my
lifetime you didn't think it would it's
a total historic moment in our country's
history
and yet
it's not as i said it's not the end
now as for that next step there's a plan
to take the fight to the state
legislatures to continue to push for
more restrictions even at the the
federal level of prohibition on those
mail order abortion peels
well you know jane we all had a heads up
with that leaked draft but i thought it
was interesting that you said last half
hour that even though we had the heads
up people on both sides were surprised
dependent didn't matter where you stood
you were it was sort of jaw-dropping no
matter what you felt why do you think we
were so surprised
i just think that's been roe has been
with us for a generation or more of
women and the court came so close to
overturning it in 1992 fell one vote
short many people thought the issue was
over and so
i think there was some complacency and
the question now is because people were
surprised what does that mean for these
women you know the states that are most
likely to ban abortion or restrict
abortion are states where women are in
most need so what are the programs there
for these women obviously the
anti-abortion groups say they're working
their programs already in place in a
number of states governors we saw a
governor gnome on face the nation
yesterday saying she has a website
trying to get resources for pregnant
women who no longer can access abortion
are those programs going to be enough
are they going to work are we the media
and others going to continue the focus
on these women who now right now don't
have the health care they need before
the decision on friday
yeah jan picking up on the subject of
surprise you've covered personally the
supreme court for almost 30 years you've
got a best-selling book on the topic
there are a few people more
authoritative you've interviewed four or
five justices sitting on the court now
did anything in this process surprise
you
no no i mean as we saw in the piece
there's been an orchestrated campaign to
try to get more conservative judges on
the courts that have conservative legal
philosophies and that's what they've
done i mean these judges believe that
you read the constitution very narrowly
liberal judges believe you should read
it more expansively and so i think the
writing was on the wall
and that's why republicans have spent so
much effort trying to get the senate and
here's what the result was today or
friday
there it is all right jan thank you very
much more to come for sure